rather than invoking an actually
existent past and comparing it with the
present i think it's
i think the the point of which from
which we can criticize the current
moment the point at which
it can be found wanting is by the is in
terms of the futures
that were projected from the 20th
century not the actual existing
past you know that it's the shocking
difference
between uh what we thought might have
happened
um and what actually has happened
and in the face of that i think we're
almost offered
a an opposition between
a certain kind of politicized
melancholia and
uh depression politicized malacholia
would be a refusal to adjust to the
present moment
refusal to adjust it is to say i can't
accept this
yet uh you know if we're not to a seed
if we're not to completely submit to
this
mr president where the future has
disappeared um you know what remains
is a certain set of longings um
yearnings etc
and it's a kind of fidelity to those
yearnings and longings that
is one of the things that i track in in
the book really
[Applause]
[Music]
i was speaking to my mic rather than
rather than to you
[Laughter]
all right why don't we kick it off there
welcome to
the pale pod this podcast is available
in the following formats
spotify that's not a format mp3
but now something new this episode only
we will be releasing an nft format uh we
are going to start the bidding at 50k
which is good because we only have to
split it three ways today
sweet uh expecting a millionaire soon
enough
so uh 50k start the bidding you can uh
dm matt on twitter don't dm me
so the [ __ ] cast that on me
this is an arrangement on the pale pod
that we've
never had before but it's me
pills matt mcmanus and mike
watson hey mike hey hi there how is your
ass
gonna split something three ways i'd
probably make it
sixty thousand just for the math okay
why not
it's bubble money so what is ten
thousand dollars
among friends anyway right how is your
uh crypto portfolio
actually i said i don't like to speak
about it because it's like
making out that i have money or
something or you know i have
amounts of investments but uh the little
i have is looking good yeah
yeah i keep i keep i'm i'm never gonna
do that because it's too many
too many transfers but i always look at
the numbers going up and go
[ __ ] i there goes my chats oh another
chat oh there goes my chance again
i don't know how you would call it
schoolboy errors i think this time i'm
avoiding some of them
all right on well i'll have to get some
uh trading advice from you afterwards
though though even though obviously the
value
of currencies is more or less arbitrary
not
completely arbitrary but uh there's
still an imaginative leap
that that kind of [ __ ] requires that i
am still unwilling to take as of yet
you grab any of that beeple speaking of
which ah
that would be good okay so
all three of us are sitting
uncomfortably
with one foot in the academy and one
foot in the internet
internet denizens mike is an internet
denizen
in addition to being i mean i hope this
is okay
a frankfurt pupil can we go there
we got that real critical theory in here
so if you've been around our little
pocket of the internet
uh mike and i pills worked together on a
video about a year ago
about the commodification of
anti-capitalist art
and we said at the end of that video
that memes could
represent a form of resistance to
commodification
and dammit mike i guess we were wrong
well yeah i suppose the thing is
what what did we really say or something
i've said also in
in my last book second book canon left
learnt to meme in the next book
the meaning of mark fisher um
you know there's a potential for
abstraction within within meme making
but it's less the it's less the
individual memes it's more
the sum mass of all memes which creates
an abstract hole
which can be disorienting and can kind
of throw off the
kind of rationalist capitalist system
hopefully um
i don't know it obviously doesn't look
like it's doing that when you're getting
people making uh
millions of selling and memes and nft it
looks like exactly the opposite is
happening
i'd still wager there's a lot more memes
not making anyone any money and just
annoying them
so you know i think the memes generally
have the effects sort of disorienting
people and not having any particular use
value
yeah i mean some of those memes that i
see you still posted around the internet
basically have to be like roman
artifacts in internet time
like there's the one with kermit
drinking the scotch and i'm like damn i
remember seeing that all the way back in
2016. my republican uncle tweeted that
all the time
to like trump [ __ ] post and i'm like
2016 by now
is like an eternity ago in the internet
wait wasn't he drinking tea was it tea i
thought it was supposed to be scotch is
what tournament had or something that's
the point you know he's the [ __ ] frog
and he wants to get hammered because the
world is like too full crap
you would see scotch where everyone else
sees tea that's true
a few days ago disaster girl the girl
looking uh into the camera in front of a
burning house
sold for 500 grand beetle
the artist who puts out a piece of art
per day i have no idea how he does that
but uh sold the world's
third highest sale for a living artist
behind uh jeff coons and some other dude
69 million dollars for a jpeg
kings of leon released an album as an
nft
and even some institutional artists like
takashi murakami are getting on the
train
selling uh jpegs
kings of leon are still together it has
been a minute
since your sex was on fire but yes holy
[ __ ] i can't believe it
yes they are really wow
that's like finding out that like oasis
are still around i can't believe it
okay i'm sorry i know that has nothing
to do with anything but i'm just blown
away by that fact but the
also the hackers are also in there
selling forgeries trying to
uh pass their their whatever you call
them the blockchain thing off as
uh originals by people but they're not
um people's thing was right ahead of
jeff's orange
balloon dog what's the orange balloon
dog one again
you know those giant balloon dogs that
are made of like uh
i don't know fiberglass or aluminum or
whatever they are
no not a clue i'm gonna jeff kuhn's
giant
balloon sculptures are more or less the
symbol of the kitschy
banality nihilism of modern art uh
okay i see i'm surprised though cause
there's like meme royalty have they
sold yet that one with a cat and a
blonde girl
is still really popular i see it like
trending all over the place
just the other day one of my students
sent me one and i was impressed because
it was still the [ __ ]
the willy wonka meme you know the one
with gene wilder and he's sitting there
looking all smug and [ __ ]
all right so uh mike i wanted to ask you
getting
getting into the content a little bit
here um
as with a philosophy background you read
not the not the frankfurt germans but
more the romantic germans like
khan tegel heidegger the way that they
talk about art as this quasi
religious gateway to a new world of
experience or portal to the beautiful
itself
and now it's a racket so how do you
square that in your mind whole new world
a dazzling place you can't opens for me
the transcendental i could never see
it's only phenomenal okay
matt i think i speak for all of us in
saying that was
sublime i think the racket came in
actually via adorno
but he wouldn't like that kind of
statement
um but i guess it was just a kind of
a move from some romantic notion of
of beauty as a unifying factor coming
down from ken
or some ideal of perfection or at least
a perfection to be attained to
um it was kind of a shift from that to
everything basically is screwed
but let's still use our anyhow and then
art moves from being a kind of
aspiration
to to beauty as a kind of so
one second like adorno and horkheimer
saying everyone is screwed
never not on my watch would you say that
yeah because they were good time guys
they were just like
they were the guys she wanted at a party
i must have them mixed up
but um yeah adorno was uh
characteristically
negative i mean he was he was he was
known for being very negative people say
melancholic but
i mean i think that's kind of polite um
or elena it's using kind of
archaic language for for a depressive
at least and i think he tried basically
to
to kind of re-fashion uh kant's vision
of artistic beauty as a kind of
a surrogate for an ethics that didn't
ever quite
happen uh so can basically use artistic
beauty
as an indicator of how we could find
universal accord where we can't find it
in relation to ethics and then adorno i
don't think he could go along with the
universal accord
on even beauty after world war ii so he
kind of said
um you know perhaps through art we can
make something
so just you know meaningless that we can
challenge the meaninglessness of
existence itself
and this also obviously um changes the
role of the artist whereas it's tied to
this
someone who's a special kind of seer or
a special kind of genius
and their work of art is tied to them
individually
uh how did this change uh with adorno
almost pointing to the absurdity of art
in general is it is it more collective
necessarily or
what would you say happens to the the
role of the the absurdity is just
more because he finds it hard to say
there can be any meaning or
any kind of sense of progress um at that
point
in in the 20th century so he was you
know
active during world war ii and after up
to late 60s
um so he's kind of grappling with
with there just being nothing seeming
good and then just like
every movement that had tried to go
along with the idea of progress
had had just failed miserably and this
is talking in a political as well as
kind of
aesthetic sense more in political sense
an aesthetic sense
so it was kind of really loath to go
along with any kind of notion of
progress
given the calamities that kind of came
about in world war ii and then recall
that he was
he was a german jew exiled uh
throughout the nazi period so
um it's really that it's there's no kind
of
aspect of bringing art down from its
pedestal it's not saying that art
is not perfect and anyone can make it or
trying to kind of
you know take take off you know
from that kind of height um it's it's
very much not that i think you still
think only an expert could make
a you know thoroughly unintelligible
piece of art
do you have to be really good at doing
it
i'm not in aesthetic theories this might
be a very naive question
uh my understanding of kant is that he
kind of operates in a weird
midway point between modern theories of
art and classical theories of art
because he does argue that the kind of
importance or what makes something a
piece of art
is that its aesthetic qualities are
purposive in and of themselves
uh they don't serve some other
utilitarian function you know
i look at rembrandt and i appreciate it
for what it is i'm not asking
why can't this painting be used for
something more useful than just my
enjoyment of it
but he does also give it a kind of
social function
in that in exposing us to aesthetic
virtues as part of a community
of people who appreciate aesthetics it
can provoke us to think more critically
and carefully about our ideas
right and it seems to me that adorno and
horkheimer take this aspect of kant's
theory of art
and really push it a lot further by both
historicizing and art
uh and suggesting that it has to play an
important political function
that it's not actually playing uh
because it's been co-opted by
the mechanisms of the culture industry
but mata does play an important cultural
function now because
the russian oligarchs got under their
money by keeping all the rembrandts in
their basement
that's true well yeah let if you're
listening any russian billionaires with
like you know
an oil rig or something uh that's not
meant to be a slag at you
but the reason i'm asking that question
is because i think that this is a chance
for us to have an interesting discussion
about
two different ways that people tend to
think about art today
uh both of which are usually juxtaposed
uh kind of sharply to one another
but what kant seems to think uh actually
go harmoniously together
you know some people say you know you
hear this from conservatives a lot like
art isn't supposed to be political art
is just supposed to be pretty things
that you enjoy for their own sake
you know a kind of classical conception
of herb but basically ken
wrote his first two critiques of
practical and pure reason
i don't remember in which order and he
was trying to find a common ethics
he was trying to prove a common ethics
on account of
the functioning of the mind rather than
than you know deities or
what have you got or what have you um
and so he wrote the third critique
as a means of introducing that
common ethics or simply common sense
like a common way of thinking a way we
could find universal accord
what he called the census communist
i think which just means common sense in
latin
um and basically what you found is that
when we for example look at natural
beauty so imagine a mountainscape
imagine being on your own maybe or at
least in silence
looking at a mountainscape and in a
certain mine there's a certain point in
which your mind
becomes suspended you're no longer able
to make
judgments and it was that suspension of
judgment he was looking for and he
basically said
that if you suspend judgment it follows
that everyone else will find universal
accord about that thing
about experience so this is why
looking at natural beauty becomes
important because you're not able to
to categorize and to measure and to to
to name
things and therefore you're not able to
form judgments
of taste as he called them as whether
something is is
good or bad or right or wrong and that's
where you get universality
and if we can have that in relation to
natural beauty it follows we can have it
in relation
to ethics but only by example
you know as in the sense that natural
beauty is exemplary
of how we can have an ethics but it
doesn't actually give us anything that
we could contribute towards that ethics
well i i would interpret it somewhat
differently but that's because i see
cant as a less conservative thinker
uh than somebody like adorno and
harcamer would and this is why i just
want to get back to like
the kind of conversation just so that we
can try to figure out whether art is
supposed to be just about again pretty
things that we enjoy for their own sake
or political because
he seems to again say that the thing
about art and aesthetic beauty
is yes we enjoy it for his own sake but
reflecting upon why we enjoy it for its
own sake as part of the census
communists
can inspire sharpening of our critical
capacities
and he points us out in the second part
of the critique of judgment where he
says
what makes my theory of nature different
than aristotle is aristotle would say
there's a kind of teleology of purpose
to nature in itself
right whereas what i'm saying is that
when you think about
it carefully enough you realize that any
purpose that you ascribe to nature
actually is coming from you you're the
one that's describing that purposiveness
to nature right and when you reflect on
that and realize it you'll be cognizant
of the fact that it's actually human
subjectivity
that's playing this fundamental role in
determining what the purposes of
existence are which is different than
what aristotle for instance would say
right and so this seems to have a
political dimension to it in
offering us a kind of freedom when it
comes to aesthetic interpretation that
you wouldn't find
in someone like aristotle and adorned
art harkemer pushed this even further by
saying
great art should really encourage us to
sharpen our critical faculties
not just our critical faculties in the
way that kant is talking about but our
capacity to be critical of things like
capitalism the culture industry uh
the mass production of banal art which
is not
certain intended to serve these
functions i just got to slow you down
for a second because uh
we're getting i never expected to get in
the weeds on cons aesthetics
but uh what we're what we're generally
saying here is that the third critique
kant's trying to get to when you see
something
sublime when you see something beautiful
there's a sense of universality in
in that that even though this site this
beautiful art this beautiful
waterfall is not doing anything for you
personally
you have the sense that there's a
universal
uh what do you call it appreciation for
that beauty
that not just you have but that
everybody else will get to it
so the art is supposed to wake you up to
the fact that
uh to the census communists which would
eventually give you this uh political
sense of
universal common sense or uh it awakens
you from this beauty because you know
this beauty is not just yours
that uh you're part of the i don't know
human community
yeah like the way i think camp would
specify it is like look aristotle says
there's a telos to nature which means
that
it's ugly if you engage in certain
activities that are unnatural like
homosexuality and a lot of aristotelians
still make that kind of argument in an
aesthetic manner
but he would say look once we realize
that you're the one that ascribes
purpose to nature
then that at least opens up a kind of
freedom for us to debate about
what things we find beautiful you know
what i mean
i think that the thing about the
romantic tradition is that
they turn on this kind of frustrating
point
that the whole point that the the whole
system
depends on on um natural beauty
having no purpose and this is what camps
can cause its per positiveness without a
purpose
um the only thing there is is once you
start to try to
instrumentalize it you lose that per
positiveness um
and it effectively becomes political and
i think
the the feeling i get from german
romanticism is a kind of yearning
for a solution to that problem that
as soon as you instrumentalize beauty or
art you lose a detachment which makes it
useful in the first place
and i think adorno never really resolves
that and i think what he's really doing
is mourning after that
that and the frustrating kind of answer
that seems to kind of languish somewhere
behind a veil
um and so we don't really get anywhere
you know i i what a dorno
where he takes it uh is he
he says that the artwork resembles the
commodity
um in that the thing about art is it
kind of
makes a claim to be beyond normal social
relations
and that claim when we're looking at
artwork leads us to kind of become
lost and we have a kind of
transcendental moment
but what dawn says what's really
important in terms of like
how we can actually live as humans is
not so much to floaty part
it's the part is it is when that
finishes so this is what he calls the
shudder
so donna would say when you're listening
to classical music you're particularly
into
um the floaty part is probably my
favorite term i've ever heard expressed
in this [ __ ] podcast
the floaty part the floaty part is the
non-fungible beautiful
yeah and he he would say you would get
lost and at some point you'd be snapped
out of that moment of
of being lost in this transcendental
moment with the music
and it's in the snapping back into
yourself that you realize uh the real
conditions of life
which are a kind of uh an awkward
kind of uh break between the subjects
and object
and so you realize that breaking you
realize it's not quite right but you
know that that's also the conditions
upon which we live
um so the experience of of
listening to art for a dawn listening to
art listening to music we're looking at
art for a door know
um it's not really a comfortable one
which leads us out it's one more that
leads us
into the problem in that snap when you
when you say you're in a museum you're
looking at a rothko
and then the guard walks past and you
snap back into yourself
it's like [ __ ] it's not like i've got
the answer it's like i have no way i
haven't got the answer
so we started this with i just want to
frame a little bit here
we started with uh kant unexpectedly i
like that we did though
um and he said an interesting thing that
i think speaks about your
book which we haven't or we think we
mentioned the title his book is uh
mike's book is memeing of mark fisher
not out yet
but we'll be out this year and i i got
the sense
it's about adorno marcusa mark fisher
and you said something interesting in
your uh explanation there about
loss because i i feel like
they're each of those in their own way
is a philosopher
of something being lost whether it's con
sublime or or some sort of engagement in
the world
and i was wondering if you could if you
would frame
your project the acid stuff as sort of
an answer
to that sense of loss is the acid left
an
answer to a sense of loss firstly the
book is called
you've got to write the main title it's
called the meaning of mark fisher
and i never say the subtitle either but
i will say it now
because it's quite long but i think it's
important um
the meaning of mark fisher how to
frankfurt school
foresaw capitalist realism and what to
do about
it so it's really about how um how
fisheries
ultimately should we say indebted to the
frankfurt school but any case he was
very much influenced by frankfurt school
which i think is an important point
because he's hugely popular with young
people now
and you know you you see young people
who are getting into philosophy online
and they're like i like fisher and uh
kind of getting into or
you know i'm starting to kind of discern
something uh
in relation to the frankfurt school but
they're kind of a bit lost but actually
uh the themes are kind of similar and
you can see just where fischer
is taking straight particularly from
adorno and particularly
in terms of their
their melancholy um depression and and
how they see
art as presenting some kind of way out
but not
an answer it's more like how art can be
utilized
um to cope with with with the excesses
of the capitalism
basically uh so fischer is talking about
how capitalism causes depression
adorno makes a similar point but never
like that
concisely um but they kind of point to
how something in in the broken hole
we can maybe recover moments of beauty
or or or moments of rebellion through
our
uh particularly through abstract art for
adorno but i think fischer is saying a
similar thing
could i just ask a quick follow-up
question to that too
that sounds personally less adornian to
me
and more kind of like what delusion
guitar we're talking about and something
like a thousand plateaus and i think a
lot of
reasons people like the losing guitar is
precisely that
adorno and harkheimer are kind of
downers just relentless downers and they
have this really nostalgic appreciation
of art
you read the losing guitar they really
liked a lot of people like the beats you
know
jack kerouac william burrows people had
this kind of psychedelic idea of
reinventing themselves in the context
of a capitalist society and how that
itself could be kind of a
countercultural activity would that be
accurate to say or
am i completely missing the mark here
for me that sounds a bit like about
adorno's uh
bourgeois nature uh he was very into
uh like again marla schomburg
edgar
samuel beckett so stuff that's really
not intelligible to the masses
and it certainly wasn't about beat
movements or
any kind of movements which try and
assemble kind of uh
you know the detritus of capitalism and
and
and and kind of build barricades or you
know kind of art
that kind of looks a bit like barricades
you know kind of i know what he was like
punky
punky type stuff wasn't into that at all
he was he was very bulge-wise
i think that's just because he was
literally bourgeois he's the parents of
all the frankfurt school ran
ran factories and things they were
industrialists basically
um so the frankfurt school of kind of
dealing with how to position yourself
within all of this
when you hate your parents but you're
actually bourgeois and you
you don't probably you know you don't
want to be one of the people with their
heads on spikes if there's a revolution
so they're nice i'm not going to go by
your factory i'm going to go become a
marxist
yeah okay before we go any further uh we
got this
it's the name of your channel it's the
name of
mark fisher's unfinished book or
unfinished project
acid communism now do you have to
do acid to be involved in this or is
that just a recommend
recommended reading okay so acid acid
communism was the name of
fischer's book and the channels called
acid left um
no you don't have to do acid no or any
or any drugs this is a
an interesting point actually not a
necessary but a recommended condition
you should do them if you want to do
them probably um we've all done them i
just don't do them anymore people don't
believe me
um it's been a long time since i since i
have done any
um but my co-host says he does and i do
believe him
um on that point um but yeah the asset
left
youtube channel we run we also have an
instagram and various other platforms we
have a patreon as well
um we're trying to capture that i think
you know i think the asset communism
idea that mark fisher talks about in his
unfinished book uh
does really draw on frankfurt school but
most obviously on marcus
because marcus got very into the protest
movement
of the 60s and he used to actually
protest with
angela davis um so he was kind of
quite different from madonna in fact
actually they got in a massive argument
in the 1969 adorno students were
rebelling in his university in frankfurt
and adorno actually called the police on
them famously because they were
occupying the building
i remember yeah didn't they flash their
boobs yeah they exposed their breasts
and he was just like oh gross
and he called the cops on them what a
[ __ ] priest actions there was an
action in german called the breast
action i don't know i can't remember the
attack german but literally translates
as the breast action
um and yeah these three students go up
on the stage rodono
and and bed their breasts and wrote
something on the blackboard but i don't
know what it was
that's probably pretty crucial marcus
actually wrote from america to adorno
because marcus stayed on after the war
i don't know how kind of return to to
people always say to rebuild
germany that sounds kind of grand but i
wanted to get involved with academia in
in germany
and marcus wrote to adorno as they often
did exchange letters and said can i come
and
and give a talk to your students address
your students in much the same ways i
used to address students
in america at the time with angela davis
and other and other figures
um and adora didn't really like that he
thought it was kind of interfering and
they basically argued backwards forward
and they talked about vietnam and and
the other students kind of
their basic objections um and one of
those things that they adjected to
everything was the vietnam war
so i think adorno is like i think that
one of his points to
to marcusa was um you basically have to
if you know if you can if you're going
to condemn violence you have to condemn
violence by the viet cong as well as by
america
i didn't know that i had never heard
that before adorno old adorno
both sides to the vietnam war what a
cuck yeah anyway i wanted to
ask uh if we don't have to do
drugs to get in drop acid uh why the
acid
what is uh can you explain that with
reference to mark fisher's
unfinished project um fischer said a few
different things but he said that acid
is corrosive but also acid
kind of evokes the spirits of the spirit
of the 60s psychedelia etc
but i think he said you don't have to
take acid certainly i think he's
he has said that at points and uh
it's more about a counter culture
developing a counter culture
equal to 60s and to rave culture in the
90s
and that culture enabling us
to develop a class consciousness and
it's a very good
you know i like that um i don't know how
it works now it seems even more
necessary now than when fischer was
writing that
i guess he was writing that in 2016 or
so
so it's important to keep this double
meaning in one sense
as it is corrosive in another sense it's
uh
i don't know trans-sensory understanding
of a whole
it's psychedelic corrosiveness they both
point to
um a kind of shifting of the boundaries
and to i think
particularly that main boundary between
us humans and nature between the
individual and the and the object
um but it's all about that you know it's
about how do we
square the fact of us being objects
and when you take psychedelics you kind
of get lost in the object
you become one with everything and you
know we take psychedelics or have some
kind of spiritual experience
and i suppose depression and psychosis
can be you know moments of losing that
boundary
and you know that can be scary for
people
um but you know the boundary isn't there
so it's like how do we deal with that
boundary that is kind of essential but
gets in the way of so much
very nice uh this sounds to me like an
expression or double articulation
of an opposition to alienation
alienation obviously as a negative term
but this corrosiveness
the acid is negating that negation
whereas something like nostalgia
is trying to answer the the alienated
negative
with something positive but that
positivity is fanciful
yes um i think i think yeah it's how do
we
confront this boundary that we've put up
how do we take it down and you know
in a way that functions you know because
if we can't just simply
take down the boundary between subjects
and object we wouldn't be able to do
anything anymore
yeah that brings to mind also uh the
marx is 1844 manuscripts when he's
admittedly a lot more
humanist about his uh goals and
intentions
but he identifies several kinds of
alienation not just
from nature and not just from our own
labor but a sort of
alienation from the species
from the human race really in absence of
any
any unified historical project
yeah that makes sense yeah
but i think then you have to mention a
time when we when we weren't eliminated
from the species has that ever been the
case
oh well in in term and what marx is
saying it's a
function of the profit motive that makes
you inclined to compete rather than
cooperate
yeah okay i also think that marx's
theory of alienation is almost always
understood correctly in a pejorative
sense
but it does have a productive uh quality
to it right in that
our alienation at least for the early
marks is part of what drives us forward
right the fact that we're alienated from
nature is why we labor to prove our
condition within nature
you know the fact that we're lineated
from one another is one of the reasons
why we build communities and why
the failure of those communities to
provide for our social needs eventually
leads to revolutionary activity
right you know alienation has this kind
of engine-like quality to it where it
destroys but then
it also breeds creation down the line in
a certain sense
i i had a question though uh mike that
actually
this is kind of really really down to
earth speaking as like a guy who teaches
students right
people students in my class [ __ ] love
mark fisher just worship the guy
uh like i was saying before we began
this
people you know gen xers have kurt
cobain
us millennials kind of had david foster
wallace and amy winehouse
a lot of zoomers i know just like him uh
and i think one of the reasons they like
him um we can talk about the depression
angle later on so i think that's really
important
is because he occupies this kind of
midway point
between academia and being kind of an
activist
cultural figure uh and the reason why is
more popular than someone like adorno is
because i think a lot of them think that
adorno is
in his attitude and disposition pretty
much kind of a square you know what he
says might be radical but
you know if you've had this idea that if
you hung out with a dorner at night uh
it would be
classical music talking about theory uh
and then [ __ ] on rap music or
whatever whereas a doran
yo mark fisher you'd probably hang out
smoke join
talk some deep [ __ ] late into the night
so they like him for that reason
right and i'm just wondering if you can
talk about
whether you think this is a good thing
to have figures that
occupy this kind of cultural space
between the academy
uh and pure activism that are seen as
act as like intellectuals but
hip accessible a little bit edgy you
know all the kind of things that give
them a certain kind of currency
yeah i mean this is the thing this is
where the book
is called the meaning of mark fisher
because what a frankfurt school talk
about and fisher a lot
is the way that capitalism co-ops
counter-culture
and the book is about how that's you
know really
happening now particularly you know
in relation to fish or at least you know
there's this irony that fish who talked
about the co-optation of culture
or of counter culture has been so far
co-operated
as a meme he's become a meme and the
meaning of mark fisher
the the you know the making meme of mark
fischer
um does kind of [ __ ] with his message a
bit
i think it makes he makes it kind of
silly or or just i mean silly might be
one thing but it makes it just very
negative and
cynical often there's a lot of edgelordy
type statements coming out
about fisher or there's like you know um
there's the one with the bed and it has
capitalist readers and bed sheet
covering it
and then it says in the remember that
impact font
uh we [ __ ] on the fisher bed tonight
and it's just it's funny because
it's funny because it's so ridiculous
and a bit sad because it's like
all you can get off that is like
laughing but then going
[ __ ] that's really where we're at that's
just that you know that's what
what fisher comes to now in a way that
you don't get much off that meme it's
kind of
it's kind of repellent in the sense it's
throws
something back at you you don't really
get to any kind of theory or any kind of
idea for praxis or actual practice
so the book speaks a bit about that
and you know fisher himself set up a
facebook page about dysfunctional
dysfunctionality of
capitalism um which was all kind of told
through
through broken machines like broken
vending machines and then
kind of dark looking toy robots and
things i don't know what
and i remember being on it uh
was it around 2015 and
and people who were following the page
and there were several thousand
followers
um decided to see the numbers dwindle
like rapidly fairly rapidly steadily
over a few hours then it was realized
because fisher said it on his own
profile that fish would taken everyone
off taking all the followers off because
the only way to actually
disable a page back then was to was to
take all the followers off was to remove
followers one by one so he got so angry
at the page because he made it to be
kind of about capitalism critiquing it
but it become a stupid meme page that
kind of wasn't able to do what it was
trying to do
um because everyone was just [ __ ]
posting so it become like
broken capitalism in itself uh he got so
upset by this he actually took the whole
thing down you imagine that he would
have probably actually been quite
literally embittered otherwise you
wouldn't have the energy to just take
everyone off one by one
so one can only imagine that he might be
a bit annoyed at how he's been taken now
well what's the right way to deal with
him then right because
i'll be honest right like the way that i
pay tribute to
mark's titanic legacy right is in a
really boring way quite frankly you know
right now i'm writing a book
emergence of post-modern culture for a
poor car or mcmillan and
you know there's a section on mark
fisher where their footnotes you know
fischer mark
capitalist realisms or blah blah blah
it's pretty dull you know what i mean
from you know a cultural standpoint uh
so i think that some of the stuff that
you're talking about and that you
discuss in your book
shows that people are being creative
with his legacy and his image and his
ideas
but then there's all the risks that
you're talking about right so
what what's the right balance to say the
thing is i do i do like that it's
happening in some respects this is the
awful thing though when you're
a little bit older and dealing with
these themes and you want to sometimes
say you know hey that's not really on
you want to shake people up and say
that's not the right way but then you
become obviously the
boomer um yeah
i mean i think it needs to lead to
praxis at some point it's all great if
it gets people excited it gets people
involved
if somewhere along the line we actually
have the
in real life meetups you know that fish
have suggested in in
uh the unfinished book acid communism
and he talks about
you know networks of learning and
consciousness raising exercises and
concerts you know but things that that
get people together and give them
you know feeling of class consciousness
and and of why things are happening the
way they're happening i
an awareness of capitalism remarks etc
um i don't know
if that's going to happen i got a
feeling it could happen after
lockdown something could happen because
people are going to want to get out
again
and a generation that's basically not
really gone to university in the
traditional sense because they haven't
got to actually go there
and partying whatever you are going to
want to go out and and
you know get crazy in the streets and
you know unfortunately they're going to
meet a load of right wing people who
want to do the same i don't know which
way it's going to go but there is there
is that potential more than maybe before
but it needs directing so the question
is how do we direct that through the
internet
and uh that's that's really up to us
it's up to people like us obviously
um people will probably be more of a
following than me but you know i suppose
as a writer i have my role
all right since you brought up praxis uh
i would like to combine two questions
into one if i may
we have this disagreement between adorno
and marcusa in the 60s over protests and
and activism and so on
basically marcus are calling adorno to
to bourgeois or whatever
and then this reflects in a lot of ways
uh
the bind that the left generally is
still in
and we can call that or we could say
both the academic left
and the online left which uh the three
of us
like i said have kind of a foot in both
of those worlds
and mark fisher stands in in a strange
position i was going to ask you the same
same question matt did in in terms of
are we in a mark fisher bubble because
it just seems
like everybody on on posting pages
know who mark fisher is and almost his
uh
his sources jameson for mostly they're
never brought up
but in the academy you never hear about
mark fisher at all
pretty much it's usually all about
jameson
and culture industry and things like
that so i wondered if you
had some sense of a praxis
that brings academics and the internet
left together or are they separate or
they just fundamentally
i had a colleague of mine who um i won't
name him but
he called fisher an intellectual
lightweight
spinning off regurgitated postmodern
theory from the 1990s
which i thought was really unfair since
there's a lot of originality
in all of his books i would say well you
get that with anyone who's popular right
like they call zizek a lightweight and i
i think there's
nothing further from the truth but
anyway i'm interested in how the praxis
crosses those uh gatekeeping boundaries
yeah that um that's tricky i mean
i think everyone has to look at
themselves really and and
look at to what extent their academic
activity or
online expertise is really contributing
something
or to what extent it's like giving one
an excuse to be
without getting their hands dirty you
know i think that
the thing with talking about
working class people or
people in developing countries or
immigrants
to to western countries
is that you're able to observe them from
a distance
it's a bit like looking at them through
a telescope the way you know the fact
that one is talking about them online
you know means that you're not actually
going and talking to them in real life
and would you
really want to in many cases i think
many people
in the academic left really want to go
and talk with the poor people
um you know i think that there's a
an element of stasis with academia and
it's a middle-class pursuit aimed at
keeping the middle class in the middle
and i think this is what you're alluding
to marcus says
to adorno i believe it's irresponsible
to sit
at one's writing desk advocating
activities to people who are fully
prepared to let their heads be bashed in
for the cause
yeah i think what you said really
resonates with me
right um you know i've done my fair
share of activist politics though i
should do more
it's easier now that i'm back in my home
country and not in mexico but
the thing is i don't think a lot of
people go into left-wing academia
because they're really all that
interested in activism they do into it
because frankly
it's kind of a glamorous activity it
allows you a bit of a punk credential
without actually doing anything that's
all that risky
and you can see that in the kind of
disposition a lot of academic leftists
take where
the irony the irony is that a lot of
them can be
just as status and class oriented as
anyone else uh like i've met
people who swear by karl marx and who i
know in the academy
who nonetheless will sit there and be
like oh you wrote for that journal
and we all know what's meant by that
journal right you know it's not harvard
law review
i think really like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this right yeah
it's while they're writing a critical
marxist analysis
of class in the novel jane eyre
i mean there's nothing wrong with with
academic marxism it's just you know
there's kind of a weird difference
you know man i don't feel like it's very
marxist
he said there's nothing wrong with
academic marxism i mean there might be
something wrong with it i don't think
it's a given that there's nothing wrong
with it
okay well there's nothing wrong with
approaching
subject matters in an academically
rigorous way from a marxist standpoint
let's put it down i i understand yeah
yeah um with 120k your salary
yeah i mean i mean it's a tricky one
because i hear me david harvey i'm sorry
hey david harvey earned his stripes he's
podcasting for the people now
that's true true i mean i don't i mean
look at the art world this is a worst
case in a way and
and i was i've worked a lot in the art
world and you have these
these exhibitions about about people
capsizing in their boats in the
mediterranean there's so many of these
exhibitions
and then probably not now because the
focus has changed and the museums aren't
open but
i mean two or three years ago you know
there were so many shows about
the migrant crisis in europe and and
there were never
migrants there there were migrants
coming into europe there were so many
you could see so many
living on the streets i was living in
italy in rome at the time and because
they had very
bad mismanagement of the of the
immigrant housing
program there were many immigrants
living in the streets so you would see
them day
in you know day after day more and more
because many of them came to italy as a
first point of call when they were
coming into europe
um but you know there was always this
big gap between
the museum and the art world and and
and these immigrants these migrants it
really was
it you know it's a kind of absolution of
guilt people couldn't
face these pictures and newspapers of
babies washing up on the beaches
and there's a need to do something um
i think it may be it's systemic in a way
that the people just don't know what to
do because they're not supposed to know
what to do we're not supposed to really
get involved
we're not allowed to change the world
the the disposition of stasis is
systemic and i do
allude to this in the book when i'm
trying i'm trying to explain i'm trying
to account for the fact that the
uh benjamin is so bourgeois and i think
i kind of like
move around that topic why why do we
have so much frankfurt school on our
reading list
probably because it's not very dangerous
you know i think you have to assume that
if anything is on all the university
readiness
it's not really a threat but on the
other hand i do kind of concede
that if you were middle class you know
in the last century or whenever or
whenever did
they then you know your way of
processing
um the social in your way of processing
social stratification
and then your way of doing something
about it is
is going to be very different to to to
working class
uh leftists and probably it's going to
be one of self-preservation going to be
a
posture of self-preservation more than
anything
and lest we are just pointing out the
plank in our brother's eye
we're all sitting here with our nice
microphones in our stable
rich countries not doing much more than
fantasizing about what we could do in
some other time
than the present so let's be real about
that
it's a similar thing it is a similar
thing yeah but and actually a lot of our
circle
go well you know what you know i i
make podcasts i have one role i i'm part
of the media or the online media or
academia or something and they're kind
of a bit surprised i've had
people kind of shift uncomfortably
talking about this kind of thing
i think we are doing a similar thing
you know i think i think i think surely
the one of the first ways to overcome
this
is at least to admit it you know the
the by doing this
we're not you know doing something more
more handsome sure we could do
both but look that's where the fantasies
just at
these days be part of organized labor
that's where the real practice is
[ __ ] matt i know you have and i have
been involved in labor action
labor disputes spoiler the employers won
and the union leaders were there
live streaming [ __ ] instagram so they
could get another union job the next
year
sorry go ahead stand out there
with my placard and my a
red flag but pretending like we're still
in 1890s
belgium doesn't constitute real action
and if that's the choice i'd rather run
an educational podcast
that people get something out of then
fantasize that strikes
make any [ __ ] of difference i mean bruh
well i think i take it a different way
right first i i always say to people
i don't think that anybody should be
blamed for the country that they live in
or the class that they belong to
uh you should be blamed if you don't
reflect critically upon that and realize
the problems
uh of enjoying certain kinds of
privilege that are denied to others
right i mean there are a lot of people i
know who grew up in
very precarious backgrounds uh who grew
up to be
trumpist as [ __ ] let's just put it that
way right very very trumpous
very much i made it from the bottom to
the top uh i deserve everything that i
get
everyone else from my hometown met a lot
of people in mexico who felt this way
actually
can go [ __ ] themselves right uh and i
know some people who came from middle
class backgrounds who are
very active on the ground and dealing
with issues um
a child poverty like you know various
kinds of diseases
earthquake you know relief you name it
right uh so i don't think that you know
your situation is destiny uh i do think
that a lot can be determined by how you
approach that
uh when it comes to the issue of you
know what it is that we can do i
absolutely agree with pills
and with you mike that we need to be a
lot more active on issues that
make a difference to people in a
concrete way and we were actually
arguing about this amongst ourselves a
little bit last week
uh when one of us said it seems
sometimes like there's no hope you know
what can we possibly do
to change things uh and my kind of
response to this was look like
the way that you have to kind of sell
the population i hate to use that term
but it's true
on radical change is by what boss garcia
cara talked about in my mind in the
socialist manifesto
help people see how the world can be
changed five years from now
why their lives would be better and how
it can be done
feasibly right and i think that's
something that a lot of people
like ourselves who engage in fury really
aren't that good at you know we're very
good at criticizing we're less good at
the
here's what will happen five years from
now if you end up supporting our radical
party
this is why you'll be better off and why
your kids will be better off a couple
years down the line
right i do see boomer activists who are
bits
technophobic and they'll say things like
real activism is only when you're
marching on the street and
i'll sometimes say yeah you know
definitely if you're never marching in
the street
you're probably you know an armchair
activist but there's nothing wrong with
sitting there and producing content
online that mobilizes people that's
interesting
that all takes work and time and effort
and you deal with [ __ ] and backlash
because of it yeah yeah
i mean i i think the the thing
that i always take from a dorner and i
think this is why it's ended up
probably in all all three of my books um
and it's just something i've been
looking at since i studied myself at ba
level
when i was just kind of struggling with
the door notebooks and picking out
phrases i can actually understand um
um it's this thing of you know we're
kind of basically
screwed but we have to do something
anyhow and that's something should be
art and you know this goes back to the
famous line of uh making
after auschwitz or in fact you know it
being impossible to
to write lyric poetry after auschwitz
which he writes in a couple of essays
but
i always take it from his essay on
commitment i think it was 1960
was it 61 or 62. and basically
he says this like yeah it is impossible
to make write poetry after auschwitz and
everyone sees us on that one line but
then he says later
but we have to keep making and he
literally says are anyhow
so that we don't spend us a cynicism so
it's like this we can't do it we have to
do it anyhow
and and him saying we can't do it really
means that the conditions to make
are you know in in the canteen sense of
something transcendental
can't exist uh in the society that's
also responsible for
the holocaust for example um
so the point being that it has to be so
controlled that nothing like heart can
exist because you know
the holocaust was was about identifying
people
you know to the degree that you could
then uh
should we say reappropriate them as it
killed them and and use the resources as
part of the war effort
that's how far capitalism become so they
come that far there can't be anything
called r but then the dawner says
we have to make it anyhow and i suppose
that's where r is illusory it's
something that we can always kind of
manage to leverage from somewhere from
some corner of our mind
and i think this you know there's
nothing left to be done but let's make
our
anyhow is the basic posture of what i
wrote wrote in the last book and the
left learned to meme
the basic posture of the millennial but
now we would probably say the zuma
by now but you see them like having
basically no hope
but constantly just doing stuff on their
phones
and they are making stuff they're making
memes they're making selfies and they
can be to some degree artistic
um you know they're constantly making
they're affirming identity
and i think that's all we can do i think
that's what we can do and it is what
we do do which is why i say in
the last book um the millennial
generation
is the adornian generation but only in
that one sense
and i think that would apply to the zuma
generation as well
and this is the kind of problem that i
think a lot of people have when they
hear a radical art experimental art
transformative art
uh they think oh so now all of a sudden
i'm gonna have to watch something that's
essentially
unwatchable it's like jean lucador film
rather than just getting to come home
from my job sit down and engage in the
at least entertaining stuff that the
culture industry has to offer me
and i talked about this with alfie brown
also when it came to video games
do you know how to answer that how can
we make radical art that
is transformative as transgressive but
people won't look at it and just say
unless i was some cafe swelling
[ __ ] parisian intellectual high on
absinthe
uh you know this isn't a piece of trash
or this is just pretentious tribe
um well i think this is far from a dorno
but i think it's
where people make it themselves then
then they're not going to be
disturbed in that way i think that's
that's what we're getting to now is that
people were constantly making
stuff themselves but you know like i say
this isn't a tool of dorney and this is
where adornian
right you know adoring some kind of kind
of fails us
um just because he was so bourgeois and
removed
i think you have to somehow get a door
knows concepts to meet up with
with um situationism for example
so yeah that would be that would be my
answer there you know i mean i think the
thing is we have to use a door no and we
have to use
you know the frankfurt scores we have to
use everyone delivers marks
um but we have to use about how we want
we have to take bits
and rearrange them and mix mix and match
them with other people
i think that's very much the case with
adorno that
he's just so wrong and so right at the
same time
yeah um i have a bit of a thesis when it
comes to this because i've been
thinking and talking and posting about
art for a while
is not to see our as the one product
of the one individual because if you
think of that then you look up where are
the great artists well they're nowhere
but something you said uh way earlier in
the conversation mike is like it's not
it's not about the one meme that makes
it it's about
almost the mass of memes if you have a
movement
of leftist stuff a flow of leftist stuff
like just for example one of the reasons
i decided like i wanted to
start a youtube channel it wasn't really
because i was just bored one day it was
because
on youtube all this [ __ ] is made by the
right wing and that right wing stuff
changes consciousness it changes the
discourse
in in the broad general sense and i was
like well if they can [ __ ] do that
i know that the leftist ideas are better
they would they should be catching on in
place of this garbage
so i i kind of think of art as not don't
attach
what can i do to one thing but more
do your one little part and do or have
someone else do their little part
then do collabs like we're doing collabs
right now but
if you have enough flow we can just
separa or call art
content now because that's basically all
it is anyway unfortunately
but that's totally stripped of this
romantic vision
of the genius alone in their house
creating uh the next uh albrecht durer
painting or something like that i
actually think that your argument for a
kind of democratic approach to art
uh is really the more radical way to go
than what you see sometimes with adorno
who i think you're right is
but so right and so wrong at the same
time about these kind of issues
and it also runs really counter to the
way that a lot of conservatives approach
art
which is via this combination of uh
does it kind of conform to elitist
expectations about what great art is
supposed to be
and of course uh does it actually sell
and you can see people like jordan
peterson articulating this position even
in his latest book beyond order where he
says things like
very few people actually have the real
creativity to produce things that are
inspired
which is why the vast majority of
artists are
don't sell anything and only a handful
actually sell anything
you know most of you will never actually
be able to produce anything that's
actually creative
and my kind of response to that is first
off who the [ __ ] are you to say that and
secondly
yeah but a lot of people don't engage in
art because they're expecting to become
the next [ __ ] michelangelo
or jean-luc godard whatever they do it
because we live under alienated
conditions
and doing this allows them to express
this sense of alienation
both for themselves and to other people
around them who might be able to
empathize and relate to it
so it has this democratic quality to it
and the fact that these people don't
like these kinds of expression
probably testifies the fact that they
know it has a certain degree of radical
potential that if enough people
start to understand that they have these
problems through art
it might actually lead them to take
political action on behalf of those
feelings
i don't know what you think about that
but separate the art from this fantasy
of the artist yeah like
the kind of artist that a lot of uh the
kind of conception of art that you see
many conservative stuff before
is some combination of a very successful
capitalist and a romantic genius that
we've been criticizing
right and an ideal world they think the
two should go together that the romantic
genius is the one who's going to succeed
in a capitalist society we should flip
that on that head and say
you don't have to be a genius to produce
art that other people will empathize
with
and in fact if other people empathize
with it
that might mean it has a certain degree
of radical potential
since if they can see in the kind of
social problems you're facing their own
social problems
that's a good start for when it comes to
inspiring collective action
that just you know i'm spitballing i
don't have a workout theory of this but
yeah i mean it's i mean i suppose i
suppose the history of monarch has been
the history
of of moving away from that
notion of genius or even talent
and i think we've really gone
the whole way we're really there you
know anyone can make anything and
you know anyone can then become famous
and maybe rich from it but i think
there's getting you know we're getting
some kickback and then rightfully it
does pose some problems
um is what we're seeing in
facebook forums and it doesn't obviously
only apply to our applies to philosophy
as well and we know that problem well if
you know you get these bizarre kind of
forms of argumentation or people just
deliberately being you know
obnoxious um and you get the art
the kind of artistic equipment as well
um and you just get bad art as well and
just bad argumentation
i mean what is it obnoxious never
but it's tricky i mean what does one do
because the thing is there is always
that possibility that
if you know if there isn't a god being
and there isn't an actual
right way of doing anything as such we
kind of moved away from that
and we you know after shedding god we
just shared experts as such
and hierarchies you know we'd like to
but we know we have culturally to a
large degree
shed those hierarchies then we leave
ourselves open that maybe the answers
you know such as such they can even
exist now but kind of
the modes of being that are now going to
come about could come from anywhere that
you know who are we to say that this is
wrong or this is right
um it gets very tricky you don't want to
be the one saying this is wrong
but i think when it gets to ethics we're
still able
to some degree to argue that there is a
superior
ethics although it's not the one that
wins out in elections
unfortunately um but you know
within our kind of academic and arts
fear and whatever we're able to kind of
argue and it seems to quite simply be
about
not causing other people pain
deliberately that still exists
well here i'll give an example of what i
mean because i completely agree with you
mike that these are all worries i have
whenever i've moved too much in a
democratic direction which is just that
anybody's gonna be able to say you know
my position is as valid as anyone else's
uh my arguments are just as right as
yours even though you might have thought
through them a little bit more
all that's extremely dangerous so i
don't want to go full promo
when it comes to my democratic account
of art when i'm thinking more when it
comes to solitaristic art that's the
term i'll use it it's something like
what cornell west is talking about and
race matters so we all know
adorno just had this really crappy uh
interpretation of jazz
right and blues is being kind of
derivative not particularly interesting
uh limited transformative potential but
cornell west points out that if you
think about jazz and blues
uh they managed to express the feelings
of a very long suffering people that
have been marginalized for hundreds of
years
and it they did so with an aesthetic
language that resonated
both within people of that community and
you know the white oppressors
who started to recognize that in the
trauma of that music
they were seeing the kind of oppression
that they were inflicting upon others
reflected back towards them which is a
very painful thing to do
and when i heard wes put it that way all
of a sudden what seemed like
kind of mass music actually has a lot of
radical potential
to it right it really kind of compels
the oppressor to think a little bit
about the horror of what they're doing
while providing a solid risk basis
for a long-suffering community so in
that sense i see it as a democratic
solitaristic kind of urn
in a way that adorno wouldn't have right
and so that's the kind of thing that i'm
thinking of when it comes to a solid
wrist guard
i don't know if that makes sense but
yeah i mean i think that does make sense
but i think
i think i'm sure you already have this
in mind as you said it
um you know there was this co-optation
of
of jazz music and then anything like
that gets corrupted the message
basically just
you know kind of kind of disappears uh
you know i think i think the thing is
there is there is fundamentally
you know in hollywood and also in in
mainstream music aesthetics there is a
kind of inbuilt ethics it's like lowest
common denominator
ethics no one want to hurt and no one
will want to hurt anybody deliberately
the kardashians would say this you know
everyone is saying
the chain smokers it's a system
that this it's part of a system that
does cause
untold pain so you have this problem
that
there's no problem maintaining the
lowest common denominator
ethic but it's being maintained
kind of overtly whilst covertly the
exact opposite is being done
and i don't know how we're going to get
how we're going to get around that
because that's how you manage to have
you know these
heinous right-wing governments still
elected because they kind of
masquerade behind that lowest common
denominator ethics it's all to do with
the family you want your family to be
well don't you you want a
little jenny and johnny to go
to school you know without any problems
and be safe and what have you and that
appeals to people's like
basic ethics sense you know then their
neighbors whatever
um but it's only that there's nothing
behind it so you still get them to vote
for
for something you know morally
reprehensible
or ethically reprehensible so i don't
know i mean you're able to have this
kind of
apparent cultural democracy
that kind of lets everyone do everything
whilst
you present this facade of well anyone
could everything but you know
also let's not hurt each other and then
you're still able to kevin's still able
you know to to basically in its economic
format
carry on untold exploitation so i don't
know i i'm
i'm going to wear it also where i'm
really going with this except that
um you know
where in that are we going to free up
the revolutionary
potential of anyone being able to make
anything
you see what i mean oh i think you're i
think 100 right i mean fischer pointed
this out right that
punk when it started was genuinely
revolutionary music right it was angry
it was visceral
it was targeted it very quickly became
co-opted by the system
uh and turned into blink 182 uh not that
there's anything wrong
with exactly what yeah what i mean to
say by that just to kind of get
get what i was saying to a kind of point
so now it makes sense why i was saying
it
is that we have any anything goes
bookended
by a kind of very neat walton style
morality on the one end
and exploitation of the developing world
on the other end
you see what i mean and in between that
anyone can do anything as long as they
don't they don't challenge
those to those two extremes so
you know i just i think that ultimately
i can't see how that's all going to
collapse
unless we just really do let
you know anyone can do anything go to
its absolute extreme such that it ends
up
kind of you know we somehow need to just
smash all that and i can't see how we
can do it except
by letting the internet push through and
it sounds kind of accelerationist which
isn't really what i want to say but
we're caught between
a void and another void
he's avoiding the best yeah the void and
the abyss just the thing that you we
wouldn't end up surely of anything
better but but you know the thing is
what
you know somewhere from all this when
you think if any anything goes anyone
can do anything
then we can no longer hold on to
expertise and then from all that
because anyone is suddenly doing
anything then something
new can emerge and it's not a swastika
because we want to re-emerge
we want the completely new thing we
haven't ever thought of to emerge well
we get into debates like or debates or
conversations not really a debate but
conversations like this and it's like
well what do we want
what do we allow to happen what are we
worried about
happening but ultimately it doesn't
matter whether you're worried
or whether you don't want something to
happen or whether you want to establish
rules because those rules aren't going
to be followed
anyway so i i guess i
it's a hopeless position in a sense but
ultimately you have to just make sure
you're ahead of the curve and
for myself you have to be making better
content than
that ben shapiro's making you know the
kind of response that i have
is that back in the early 2000s i
remember a lot of progressive became
kind of digital utopians that the
democracy of the internet would allow
everyone to produce art
and then gradually that would lead to an
undermining of the system and we've
completely seen that that hasn't
happened
right uh in fact if anything as uh you
pointed out and as pills pointed out
many conservatives have learned how to
use new digital spaces more effectively
than leftist
which is [ __ ] baffling but you know
it is what it is right
but my response to that would be look
you know it's in some sense it's a
practical problem
uh we just need to find a way to as you
put it in your
second book mean better you know we need
to produce better internet channels
better content
uh things that work more effectively and
inspire people
and then gradually we can hope to see
this generate real activism
on the streets and i mean it's not
something that any of us can do
individually right like our little
[ __ ] corner of the internet
might inspire a few people but you know
we're not gonna [ __ ] start the
plastic pills revolution
you know acid communism uh you know
might has this corner of the internet it
might inspire a few people
but you know i don't imagine you're
expecting you know that people are going
to be carrying your flag in the streets
you know to [ __ ] bring boris johnson
down anytime soon
but all together we can start to make a
difference yeah yeah i mean
i really wouldn't want people carrying
my flag
or any flags i suppose but yeah i i know
what you mean
um yeah we can all make a bit of a
difference
um but i think somehow we need a bit of
reprogramming i mean we can make a
difference because that's going to
involve
some reprogramming adorno spoke always
about this identity thinking so we tend
to think in terms of identifying
so we give things names measures numbers
whatever
this goes to extremes with capitalism so
we all effectively have a number
which is our monetary value um and and
in that way it's easier to exploit each
other and so he says that
the only way we're gonna get around this
is by
rethinking thought what he calls
non-identity thinking we need to not
identify we need to be able to
somehow think differently and the way in
a way that you can't really explain
which is fine because you know
philosophers often end up like that they
can't actually come up with a
with a solution you know i think we need
to be prepared to go that extra mile
because it's quite easy to get in these
discussions
and someone said something smart about
marks and someone else chips in with
something smart about marx and then they
add in some
some lenin as well whatever and then we
all know everyone's read something
but he didn't know it's true yeah i mean
that's that's like a standard academic
situation it's almost like those [ __ ]
two birds in a richard attenborough
documentary where like
it's like oh i'm gonna [ __ ] test you
and i'm gonna test you and it's like you
read this you read this and it's like
okay
we've all established that you know
everybody's everyone's read something
here okay
yeah yeah we need to go the extra mile
somehow we need to
i don't know can we can we be the can we
be the
like the last men or something or it
sounds like nietzsche
can you know can we can we be like
future humans i don't think so no but i
mean
can we at least work out how we bring
ourselves to go and speak to the actual
workers
you know i don't think many of us are
going to the supermarket and we don't we
don't want to speak to people at
supermarket
you'll probably all use a self-service
checkout i worked at a supermarket for
seven years and i can tell you that most
of the people that come in to talk to
you were [ __ ] [ __ ]
this cabbage was too expensive
but i always have to it i have worked as
well and i mean a lot of my life in
in all kinds of supermarket jobs and but
now i'm i'm
i do like visiting lecturing and
proofreading and bits of writing for
people this kind of thing but the point
is i don't recognize i'm not like a
worker i'm not in that
really crappy position of working in a
supermarket anymore for a long time so
that's the sense in which i i go let's
go and talk to the workers is like
i still think i come from a working
class background but
you know really i'm not working in that
sense and i don't go and speak to the
workers
you know and i i think that the thing is
it's about organization in a literal
sense of
organization meaning about using
different organs for different things
like you used you know you used
hammer to hit a nail etc
so you know i don't think i'm the best
person to go and g up the workers
to go and talk to a load of nurses or
something i mean i can do it
but it's people are a lot more bubbly
than me but you know i can still do
my part i can maybe see that we need to
go and speak to the workers and start to
help
organize that but has some other role
like the kind of thing i'm doing now
writing etc so i don't think we all
ought to be going and talking
to homeless and workers etc quite like
that because it would seem also awkward
and unnatural maybe in many cases
so it's a it's a body with organs we
could say
i just wanted to say still because i
want to reiterate talking about
what should happen on the internet or
what we're worried about
or what's dangerous none of that's going
to matter this
is mostly just feelings we're
facilitating sentiment
and yeah we feel powerful because we see
our leftist
friends get to 20 000 followers and
we're like damn this is really going to
catch on but at least at least at the
moment
that's an economy of feelings and vibes
because we don't have any political
leverage
and political leverage for the most part
is money or you have 2 million
followers not twenty thousand so as far
as i'm concerned you know once in a
while maybe
we get a new listener great or there's
some new articulations we come up with
great uh but that in the end is still
just vibes and don't get me wrong i'm so
glad
that people are taking the ride with us
certainly it's amazing that people care
to listen to
us just banter on about ideas
but having the right ideas is no
different from having the wrong
ideas when we're talking about the
goodness in the world to come because
whether you're
delusion marxist anarchist socialist
these are like
basically aesthetic categories when you
don't have political leverage
yeah and we don't really the whole left
with every leftist influencer combined
still doesn't have enough
political leverage and that fantasy irks
me because it's made
up that we're going to get people on the
streets and that's gonna change
something who cares
about your flag nobody nobody with money
cares so
if we're gonna do roles or organs then
yeah
great we'll keep going giving language
to sentiment
namely alienation and those thoughts
aren't even our thoughts in most cases
they're the thoughts of another
intellectual class who are comfortably
tenured at their parisian universities
or you know
but time will tell if these ideas are
relevant in the future
we might not live to see him but i'm
down well you can drop the acid in the
floor and see
the rorschach mark that it burns so do
something
who cares if it matters just do it and
we'll see anyway after all that
sorry we are on a time constraint mike
can you let us know where to find your
[ __ ]
um i mean you'd you'd find me somewhere
i mean people would find this but they
can go to
whether the acid left youtube so you
just look on youtube at the acid left
uh it's also on instagram my website is
mike watson dot f i
and that's really it the book details
will be out soon everywhere
um i write zero books right
and books coming out with zero books
yeah september 24th all right
i've read it and i can say uh you should
pick it up it's really
very interesting and whether you read
mike's uh last book or not
uh it really is just a fantastic
diagnosis
uh of where we are right now and there's
some really cool pop culture references
for
those of you who like those things so so
keep a lookout for that
and you have just listened to another
podcast where we didn't solve
all the problems of the left
unfortunately
next if we had another half hour i think
we could probably get there
we were getting it yeah i think we
covered our bases better than
so you know than on many other podcasts
wait what there are other leftist
podcasts we did a very good job of like
explaining why we're
why we we're not changing anything but
that we really want to yeah so
we should turn our attention to why we
can't change anything
instead of trying to change anything we
can we can keep going in that direction
i say that and i wish it was a joke but
i guess it's not anyway mike thanks so
much for coming
um shout out to finland thanks for
having me thank you
and for our audience uh you will hear
from us again next week
you